no no
esperan desde hace horas a más de 40
grados
a busca de oxígeno para el próximo
enfermo
esta joven cruzó la capital india por
esta botella mi padre tiene covite uno
de sus pulmones ya no funcionan su nivel
de oxígeno es muy bajo no he comido nada
desde esta mañana en busca de oxígeno
todo el día al llegar delante de la
fábrica la espera una nueva fila todos
aquí esperan poder llenar sus botellas
vacías con el oxígeno distribuido por
esta empresa y todos están desesperados
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para garantizar la seguridad se ha
desplegado a la policía y el ejército
pero ante la apertura de las puertas las
fuerzas del orden son superadas
[Música]
en nueva delhi al igual que en otras
ciudades del país se lleva a cabo una
guerra por el oxígeno
ante la falta de camas en los hospitales
muchos enfermos están obligados a ser
tratados en su casa sus familias deben
buscar por sí mismas el oxígeno esta
fábrica es su última esperanza aquí se
llenan 1000 botellas al día
no me iré a dormir mientras los pueda
seguir ayudando
mi conciencia me impedirá dormir
mientras siga teniendo oxígeno en mi
fábrica
es tan doloroso
incluso con todas nuestras reservas no
podemos salvar a todo el mundo india
produce 8000 toneladas de oxígeno al día
frente a una demanda dos veces mayor
entonces en una ciudad como nueva delhi
que cada día alcanza nuevos récords de
contagio el oxígeno se convierte en un
producto extremadamente escaso en el
parqueadero de este templo sic una
asociación instaló un driving de oxígeno
[Música]
más de 800 personas vienen aquí todos
los días algunos por urgencia vital
vienen a consumir oxígeno que les es
administrado directamente en el lugar
sordo seguido
fritzl en uno de los voluntarios trata
de abastecer la mayor cantidad posible
de pacientes las personas se mueren en
todas partes en sus casas y en las
calles aquí aunque lleguen en tuk tuk o
en un carro lujoso atendemos a todo el
mundo
tratamos de salvar la mayor cantidad de
vidas posible a causa de problemas
pulmonares provocados por el cob y el
nivel de oxígeno en la sangre de los
enfermos puede caer su vida se ve
directamente amenazada
esta mujer acaba de alcanzar el umbral
extremadamente crítico de 43 % fui a
todas partes buscando oxígeno
[Música]
pero todo el mundo me lo negó
no hay oxígeno en ninguna parte su
estado de salud se está deteriorando
en nueva delhi el campo de batalla se
organiza en frente de este hospital
público que ya está saturado médicos
voluntarios ocuparon un salón de bodas
para convertirlo en una sala de
urgencias
aquí los doctores trabajan en turnos de
24 horas
el doctor raya chain dirige las
operaciones
como ocupamos este salón de bodas no hay
tuberías
entonces contamos únicamente con las
botellas de oxígeno hasta las más
grandes se vacían demasiado rápido
llenarlas se ha convertido en un
verdadero reto
nuestra asociación ha cubierto muchos
desastres en el sur de asia pero nunca
hemos visto una situación semejante
ante la falta de apoyo por parte del
gobierno
desde ayer el doctor james no ha tenido
más opción que seleccionar a los
pacientes
haga algo se lo suplico mi padre y mi
madre se están muriendo
los de condición más graves son enviados
de regreso
no puedo hacer nada se lo digo
honestamente
su nivel de oxígeno está en 80
sin aliento india espera contar con la
ayuda internacional
en particular con la francesa que ya
está llegando